[Musik]
flughafen berlin hier befindet sich auch
eine der modernsten feuerwachen in
deutschland binnen sekunden müssen die
retter am unfallort sein es geht um
leben und tod
und wie immer steht dieses hightech
löschfahrzeug im fokus
also an diesem fahrzeug könnte man
eigentlich mir gar nicht mehr so viel
auf die mir aus können doch fliegen und
er den raketenantrieb aber so sehr
zufrieden das ist stand der technik sehr
schön schönes arbeiten
[Musik]
gut ist nicht gut genug die ingenieure
haben die herausforderung angenommen und
wollen ein perfektes fahrzeug noch
besser machen
[Musik]
in giengen werden schon seit über 100
jahren löschfahrzeuge gewarnt hinter
diesen mauern dreht sich alles um feuer
und flamme jetzt will das team die super
feuerwehr bauen
wir haben dann auch in richtung komfort
sehr viel getan wir haben dort im
fahrwerk zum beispiel an jeder achse
oder an jedem rad jetzt zwei stoßdämpfer
angebracht und dem fahrkomfort zu hören
aber das größte highlight im bereich
chassis das ist unser stufenloses
getriebe
dort haben wir die möglichkeit jetzt
praktisch vom start an bis zur
höchstgeschwindigkeit ohne unterbrechung
die leistung voll auf die straße zu
übertragen und müssen dort net mit
irgendwelchen schaltzyklen oder wandler
verlusten kämpfen es geht hier nicht um
irgendein löschfahrzeug hier wird die
formel 1 auf sechs rädern konstruiert
in den gründerjahren wurde noch
gezeichnet jetzt performt die maus am
rechner als wir arbeiten mit dem mit
creo als konstruktion ins programm
arbeiten im dreidimensionalen raum
konstruieren dort sämtliche komponenten
vom gesamtfahrzeug bis ins kleinste
detail jede einzelne schraube wird
konstruktiv festgelegt die position die
ausführung einer also das
fahrzeugkonzept der neue index
beinhaltet verschiedene einzelne auf
fahrzeug module die in funktionen oder
räumliche abgrenzung von der sich
unterscheiden so zum beispiel die
fahrerkabine dem wasserbehälter die
verbuchung kumpel oder die verkleidung
diese komponenten module sind hat jeder
sind auf verschiedene ingenieure
aufgeteilt dass jeder sich auf einen
bereich spezialisiert und diese
komponenten halt konstruiert entwickelt
alles muss in diesen giganten seinen
platz finden und genau das spornt männer
wie lukas klemmt an und er möchte seinen
rechner bis an die grenzen ausreizen
macht einer einen fehler erleben wir den
dominoeffekt deshalb arbeiten die männer
und frauen im team und tauschen sich
ständig angst haben die module am pc
bestanden geht es von der virtuellen in
die reale welt aus einer 3d animation
wird ein echtes modul
befinden uns nun in der fertigung der
neuen z baureihe hier sehen sie die
verrohrung mitsamt den pumpen aggregat
vielleicht ist dann so am stück vor
gefertigt wird herzstück des ganzen ist
die feierliche kreiselpumpe mit einer
förderleistung von 10.000 litern pro
minute
aufgesetzt auf einem speziellen grund
rahmen der eigens hierfür konstruiert
wurde um halt die gesamte verrohung vor
fertigen zu können und sie dann an stück
aus fahrzeug setzen zu können damit es
irgendwann auch in berlin zum einsatz
kommt der neue z6 wird speziell für den
einsatz auf flughäfen konstruiert und
gebaut die wachmannschaften überlassen
dabei nichts dem zufall
zwar sind unfälle auf flughäfen selten
doch wenn es passiert dann gewaltig und
immer lebensbedrohend übungen sind daher
an der tagesordnung
für die übung
heute zum üben bereitgehalten sozusagen
und ja beruflich das den schwerpunkt
legen heute ja ich denke mal das
schöffengericht nur auf liegen sich die
umgang endingen des gelenkes des
löschens das bis hin zu simple wenn man
an der attrappe sicherlich ansetzen die
denkmal zuguckt drauf dass der fahrzeuge
stetig grün auf das dann natürlich
eingesetzt wird wir werden heute wasser
einsetzen aus übungszwecken genommen und
dann los ich rufe die schuhe angehabt
der raum auslösen genommen und wer
staaten alles gleich gut
ja hallo darüber hier aus dem fcz wir
würden das gleich mit der übung beginn
flugzeug brandbekämpfung mit dem z8 wird
man bitte das crash von aus und dann
legen wir los ok alles klappt es noch
nicht wenn wir fertig sind
die männer und frauen müssen jede
sekunde im wahrsten sinne wachsam sein
es geht nicht darum eine katze vom baum
zu holen sondern ein entfernung zu
löschen und menschen aus der hölle zu
retten
dabei dürfen sie nicht hektisch über
reagieren sondern müssen mit äußerster
präzision vernunft und geschulter taktik
ihre technik zum einsatz bringen
herzstück ist hierbei die leitstelle
sie überwacht jede bewegung und
koordiniert die rettungsteams
eine falsche entscheidung kann leben
kosten
bei flugzeug brenton geht es nicht um
minuten es geht um sekunden
entsprechend konzentriert und angespannt
ist das team auch bei übungen
auf allen drei wachen pro alarmierungen
jetzt läuft die zeit jeder schritt jeder
griff jede bewegung wurde tausend mal
geübt und immer wieder optimiert
am ende sitzt man über 1000 ps die das
super löschfahrzeug binnen sekunden
praktisch zum unfallort katapultieren
[Musik]
immer vor ort mit dabei ist auch
einsatzleiter benjamin christ wichtig
ist für ihn und seine mannschaft der
faktor zeit und der soll auch durch die
technologie optimiert werden
also wir unseren löschfahrzeugen bei uns
am flughafen möchten auch in der
digitalisierung weiter voranschreiten
dafür brauchen wir navigationshilfen
ähnlich wie wir sie aus dem auto kennen
bloß speziell zugeschnitten für den
flughafen wo häufiger drauf sind damit
wir im einsatz noch schneller helfen
können binnen 180 sekunden muss das
löschfahrzeug jeden platz auf dem
flughafen erreicht haben bereits während
der anfahrt starten die männer im
cockpit die brandbekämpfung
jetzt ist es nur eine übung im ernstfall
gilt es besatzung und fluggäste aus der
feuerhölle zu befreien
[Musik]
gruppenführer lars fonds ist sich dieser
verantwortung bewusst und sieht in jeder
übung auch das reale unglück
drauf
nur das wasser zusätzlich kommen
natürlich pulver und schaum
bildner dazu versuchen die kabine
herunterzukühlen teuer nebenbei zu
löschen ist so wichtig hier die land
objekt wir haben viele menschen
konzentriert in einem flugzeug
dies geht natürlich zu retten wenn die
selbstverpflichtung nicht stattgefunden
hat dort können wir ja auch so massiv
die mengen an kerosin
sind natürlich beträchtlich
und die versuchen wir natürlich dann mit
schaum im griff zu halten
nicht nur bei der anfahrt gerade am
brandherd geht es um sekunden innerhalb
kürzester zeit muss eine enorme menge
wasser aus dem tank gepumpt und über den
massiven werfer geschleudert werden nur
für diesen moment ist das fahrzeug
ausgelegt
ein echter kraftprotz der auch gesteuert
werden muss
technik wir sind immer noch
feuerwehrmänner und eigentlich
handwerklich orientiert hier sehr viel
technik verbaut mit der man dann doch
schon sehr auseinander setzen muss was
wir ja auch jeden tag tun
das ist die herausforderung
und hier wird die nächste
herausforderung gebaut
herzstück eines jeden löschfahrzeuges
ist die pumpe
je mehr wasser in kürzester zeit auf den
brandherd trifft desto größer die
überlebenschance
allerdings wollen die ingenieure beim
bau auch gewicht einsparen
je leichter das fahrzeug desto schneller
insofern denkt man auch bei der pumpe an
die maximierung der leistung aber
gleichzeitig minimierung von größe und
gewicht
so erhält man das optimum im ergebnis
und näher gerettete menschen
jede schraube jedes gewinde wie tiere
auf geplant und getestet
gerade bei der pumpe wird das material
enormen kräften ausgesetzt
[Musik]
neben der pumpe ist der sogenannte
werfer wichtiges bauteil am flughafen
löschfahrzeug
es ist nicht ein großes gartenschlauch
gewinde nein das ist die champions
league der hochtechnologie und der ganze
stolz von software entwickler ingo boden
wir fahren einen komplett neuen ansatz
bei diesen werfer im vergleich zu den
bisherigen werfen die wir sonst gebaut
haben
wir verwenden sogenannte intelligente
motoren die uns entsprechend rückmeldung
geben wie es geht
position temperatur strom und das
ermöglicht uns auch
eine entsprechende diagnose über den
werfer zu bekommen stichwort verwaltung
telematic was mit den alten werfen
bislang nicht möglich war es ist die
königin der löschfahrzeuge der gigant
denkt lenkt und rettet dabei noch leben
was man sonst nur aus der formel 1 kennt
wird nun auch zur brandbekämpfung
eingesetzt und ja man möchte meinen es
sind große spielzeuge für große kinder
klar macht das auch spaß wenn man die
super feuerwehr bauen kann und darf
damit die brandbekämpfung möglichst
effizient abläuft wird das fahrzeug mit
zwei werfern ausgerüstet der eine wird
am großen schwenkarm verbaut der zweite
werfer befindet sich auch fahrer höhe
beide können individuell und mit
unterschiedlichen modi gesteuert werden
tatsache ist einfach die merkmale
geschwindigkeit wassermenge ausladung
des gelenks haben wohl funktionen auf
anfahrt wasser gegeben
fast jedes fahrzeug kann das sind die 24
motoren mit 135 km h spitze und
gleichzeitig den punkt motor schalten
können und es wären leistung verlieren
und wasser geben können
menschen retten ist sagt wir können da
ersetzen menschenleben nicht das ist
unser job hier
dafür trainieren
und das regelmäßig damit gerade unter
stress situationen jeder griff sitzt man
hat keine zeit nachzudenken man muss
sich in der kabine praktisch blind
bewegen können
speziell
geworden und gerade wir als
werkfeuerwehr sind ja nicht in normandie
wir können unsere fahrzeuge in unseren
bedürfnissen bauen
und das haben wir hier oben gesetzt
das ist bei rossi kopf
und damit sind eigentlich sehr zufrieden
dabei sind die feuerwehrmänner an der
entwicklung neuer fahrzeuge indirekt
beteiligt ihre erfahrungen aus dem
alltag fließen in die konstruktion neuer
modelle ein
mit der entwicklung der flugzeuge
schreiten auch die entwicklung und die
anforderungen an die löschtechnik voran
natürlich haben wir hier bei dem
fahrzeug ist das 1 der super modernsten
fahrzeuge die es aktuell auf dem markt
zu kaufen gibt also ja ich habe uns die
arbeit in verbindung mit dem löschen dem
hintergrund hier im einsatz hatten da
möglichst und natürlich wesentlich mehr
einsatzmöglichkeiten dichter an das
feuer ranzukommen fahrwerk triebwerks
brennen auf eine andere art und weise zu
bekämpfen für das bei den fahrzeugen vor
20 jahren der fall war
neben der beherrschung der technik
genießen die feuerwehrleute auch ein
spezielles fahrertraining um die
auflagen und regeln im ernstfall zu
erfüllen ein luftfahrzeug vorschriften
dieser 180 sekunden ein treff zeit von
der alarmierung bis die
flughafenfeuerwehr das erste löschmittel
am ereignisort ausbringt sind gleich
geblieben also 180 sekunden und jetzt
aktuell haben wir halt größere
motorleistung in den fahrzeugen dass wir
diese eintreffzeiten haid weiter
verkürzen können und höheren
geschwindigkeiten erreichen können
[Musik]
und ob das neue modell diese
geschwindigkeiten erreicht wird auf dem
airport in memmingen getestet zum ersten
mal nimmt der prototyp richtig fahrt auf
unter dem steuer von tobias clintons
wird der koloss an seine grenzen
gebracht
er beschleunigt eigentlich ohne
schaltung also sehr sehr kontinuierlich
und
das ist zum vergleich zu den alten
getrieben schon ein riesen unterschied
weil wir doch sehr erstaunt dass diese
schalten hat man gespürt das waren
richtige schläge das hat man bei dem
fahrzeug gar nicht mehr beschleunigt
eigentlich von null weg bis zur
endfälligkeit so richtig schön ohne
großen schaden und bürger und es ist
halt
ein neues fahrgefühl was da von diesem
fahrzeug weekend und das muss erst
kennenlernen
zum ersten mal erhalten techniker und
ingenieure echtes und direktes feedback
vom fahrzeug
fahrverhalten leistungsentfaltung lösch
module aber auch die bremskraft werden
immer wieder getestet und protokolliert
[Musik]
das war jetzt beschleunigung von 0 auf
und mit drei anschließender vollbremsung
von 80 auf 0 das wird die verzögerung
leistung war sehr gut die temperaturen
sind alle so im rahmen der erwartungen
geblieben und die performance war
besetzt also was man mit der hand
stoppuhr machen konnten sah gut aus die
genauen daten kriegt man erst wenn man
dass wir im labor falls auswerten und
natürlich werden auch pumpe und werfer
genau unter die lupe genommen hier hat
man besonders viel innovation
hineingesteckt erfüllen beide die
erwartungen funktionieren software und
hardware am airport memmingen kommt das
ergebnis jahrelanger entwicklung auf den
fast glühenden asphalt der gigant zeigt
sein gesicht vor allem der werfer steht
im blickpunkt der tester
[Musik]
brandobjekt oder ein brennendes flugzeug
hauptsächlich fahrzeug oder den brand
das bedeutet der löschschaum ist in der
unteren angriffsposition da geht es
einfach darum dass man mit langsamen
geschwindigkeiten die dynamischen
bewegungen von dem auge sehen obwohl
durchlebt aber stabil steht und so
weiter und so fort weil bei dieser
anfahrt ist es so dass die feuerwehr
quasi im anfahren beim runterbremsen vom
fahrzeug diesen armen die unsere
angriffsposition bringt und dann auf
eine niedrige schrittgeschwindigkeit
geht und dann sich langsam an dass man
das brandobjekt hinweg ist und da wollen
wir einfach sehen ob die ganzen
mechanischen sachen sowie sind also
nicht zu sehr durch schwingt der wird
immer schwingen aber es gibt ein
gewisses limit wasser halt nicht
überschreiten darf und das werden wir
jetzt im nächsten versuch probieren und
testen
dass wir das schwingungsverhalten von
dem augen haben
immer wieder wird der prototyp neu
betankt und immer wieder auf die piste
geschickt
eine schweißtreibende arbeit für die
test mannschaft
aber alle sind sich bewusst dass hier
eines der leistungsstärksten
löschfahrzeuge der welt getestet wird
und bald auch weltweit zum einsatz kommt
es muss die erwartungen in china genauso
erfüllen wir in brasilien oder in dubai
bei schnee und eis genauso seine
leistung abrufen wie bei brütender hitze
hier wurde nicht nur die modernste
technik verbaut sondern auch die
weltweit größte fahrerkabine
es sind diese superlative die aus einem
löschfahrzeug eine super feuerwehr
machen
und es ist der akribie dieser männer zu
verdanken dass der z6 nicht nur stark
sondern auch ganz besonders schlau ist
über 12.500 liter fasst der tank der
nach wenigen minuten wieder gefüllt ist
es gibt noch viele szenarien zu
durchlaufen vor allem die
unterschiedlichen modi müssen getestet
werden
hier ist die technik besonders sensibel
aber auch gleichzeitig effizient
alle daten werden im rechner
abgespeichert und sofort an die
ingenieure weitergeleitet
bei 1 manövern bringt man das fahrzeug
oft über die grenzen eines normalen
löscheinsatzes hinaus es dann ist man
sicher
so nach dem auftanken bevor wir jetzt
die endgeschwindigkeiten fahren prüfen
wir noch mal sensorisch mit der hand die
reifentemperaturen diacks temperaturen
das wenn man jetzt dann auch die
endgeschwindigkeit von über 120
stundenkilometer bringen dass wir dann
auch sicher sind dass uns von den reifen
her nichts passiert
der z6 kann nicht nur löschen sondern
wie man sieht auch prächtige reden
würden zaubern ein echter künstler
ob das auch protokolliert und analysiert
wird bleibt ein geheimnis
ganz sicher aber stehen die messwerte
über beschleunigung
höchstgeschwindigkeit
temperaturen neigungswinkel und
natürlich der bremsweg indem es tabellen
[Musik]
die zentrale in giengen bekommt ständig
rückmeldung über das geschehen auf dem
airport
dort bereitet man sich indes auf die
montage in der fertigungsstraße vor alle
module fließen jetzt zusammen
millimeterarbeit nicht nur beim bau
sondern auch beim zusammenbauen hast
alles was man in den 3d animationen
berechnet hat basis des neuen flughafen
löschfahrzeuges ist das chassis am ende
kommt das fahrzeug auf eine stolze länge
von über elf metern
vor einem breiten sich drei meter aus
und türmen sich vier meter hoch ein
echter gigant der nach dem willen der
ingenieure dennoch leicht sein soll dem
habe ein gewichtes bei uns die
gewichtsverteilung auf jeder achse haben
wir achslast von maximal 13 tonnen wir
haben da auf dem fahrzeug
gesamtgewicht von 9 30 tonner bei diesen
drei achsen und wir versuchen alles so
leicht wie möglich zu halten die
komponente so leicht wie möglich
und umso leichter wir sind das hat eine
ganze sekunde vorteil alles was mir hier
am fahrzeug an der technik leicht haben
kann unsere kunde mehr wasser mehr
löschmittel mitnehmer also bei der
fahrzeugreihe kann man jetzt je nach
aufbau und system bis zu 19.000 liter
löschmittel mit nehmer als wasser oder
schaum
der riese muss auch schnell bewegt
werden und das erfordert kraft auf allen
achsen
wir haben hier verschieden große
fahrgestelle wir haben vom zwei achse
bis zum 4 achse wir haben pro achse
immer 13 tonnen achslast das heißt wir
fangen beim 28 26 tonnen gesamtgewicht
an über drei jahre um 930 tonnen bis zum
4 achse mit
250 tonnen das hat ein riesenvorteil wir
fahren dann auch mit unterschiedlichen
motorisierungen also die zwei kleinere
fahrer wir mit 770 ps und bei dem große
haben dann zwei fahrer oder drauf und
können dann bis zu 15 140 ps als 1000
540 ps eine antriebsleistung bringen
bringt uns ein riesen vorteil unserer
kunden ist sehr schnell an seinem
einsatzort das muss man sich vorstellen
wie werden jetzt einen kleinwagen ganz
normalen stadtverkehr fährt in normaler
fließende verkehr hat man auch solche
beschleunigungswerte und das können wir
bei uns in der komplette serie dann
darstelle
jeder schritt in der bauphase wird
überwacht und gegebenenfalls optimiert
gerade löschfahrzeuge werden mit
elektronischen
assistenzsystemen unterstützt ohne
hochleistungsrechner und speziell
entwickelte software wäre dieses
fahrzeug der superlative nicht zu
steuern
man profitiert von der technischen
intelligenz und begibt sich gleichzeitig
auch in deren abhängigkeit
mensch und maschine erfahren
gleichermaßen eine entwicklung und
fordern sich gegenseitig heraus
so auch bei der sensorik für den
neigungswinkel
das fahrzeug sollen nicht nur auf der
start und landebahn sondern im freien
gelände zum einsatz kommen
formel 1 trifft auf rallye
wir haben hier ein sensor für den
überschlags warngerät das warnt den
fahrer wenn das fahrzeug sich in eine
gefährliche neigung befindet
werden dies garten in der software aus
und tun dann sprechen waren hinweise auf
dem display und akustisch ausgeben
ein flughafen löschfahrzeug kommt immer
öfter auch bei waldbränden zum einsatz
entsprechend muss die fahrtauglichkeit
im schweren gelände gesichert sein
durch aufbauten und die geladenen
löschmittel liegt der schwerpunkt hoch
daher ist das warngerät für den
neigungswinkel unentbehrlich
durch den modularen systemaufbau dann
gegeben dass man das display quasi nur
noch die befehle krieg zu anzeigen also
die ganze logik ist eigentlich im
hauptstrom geräten
und das display die befehle ausführen so
zur anzeige
am computer können alle fast szenarien
ob vater oder weicher untergrund
schräglage und neigungswinkel
durchlaufen und mit der software
gekoppelt werden
eine fahrt durch wald und wiesen am
schreibtisch
da ist auch die geschwindigkeit der
auslenkung davon abhängig wie stark ich
denn in den filter setzen wenn ich jetzt
ziemlich starke schwankungen habe die
aber nur ganz kurzfristig andauern und
sieht man es im endspiel auch gar nicht
ich jetzt nur einen kurzen kurzen rubel
hat soll es nicht gleich eine warnung
ausschlagen man halt immer nur
kurzzeitige aus schwankungen hat dann
darf sich das nicht auf das signal dann
auswirken was dann in die logik
reinkommt
durch das anforderungsprofil wird die
innovation zur serie
also setzt primär ein im flughafen
fahrzeugen weil der schwerpunkt etwas
höher liegt und durch die hohen
geschwindigkeiten der fahrzeuge da
erhöhte gefahr besteht dass das die
fahrzeuge kippen
so am pc scheint das warnsignal zu
funktionieren wie sieht es aber im
gelände aus
die super feuerwehr muss sich daher
nicht nur auf dem flughafen beweisen
sondern auch im wald
durch den klimawandel steigt die anzahl
der waldbrände und daher kommt auch der
z6 immer häufiger als brandbekämpfer zum
einsatz
florian koubsky checkt ob der z6 auch
rené tauglich ist
es so dass wir die betriebsfestigkeit
von dem fahrzeug untersuchen und die
grundsätzlichen abstimmung zwischen den
motor dem getriebe und der fall
gesprochen das heißt ich kann das
fahrzeug so bewegen dass ich nur
normalen fahrbetrieb habe aber auch im
löscheinsatz die pumpe zugeschaltet habe
und das bei geschwindigkeiten bis zu 120
stundenkilometer zum beispiel zuschalten
kann dass diese abstimmung mit getestet
wird optimiert und eingestellt
der löscht gigant betritt im gelände
neuland bislang wurde er fast
ausschließlich auf asphalt eingesetzt
jetzt muss sich der ps protz auch auf
sand gras und geröll beweisen
dass der sich in den letzten
entwicklungs stahl also ergebnis der
letzten entwicklungsrunde nist und wir
quasi finale testrunde mit diesen
fahrzeugen durchführen man kann sagen
wir haben 14.000 liter löschmittel an
bord haben motor mit 770 ps 300.000
newtonmeter und
das fahrzeug ist sehr darauf optimiert
dass wir eine sehr leise kabine haben
die auch bei höheren geschwindigkeiten
einen guten fahrkomfort bietet
fast 40 tonnen müssen über vögel
schotterstraßen und waldwege geschleppt
werden doch nicht nur dass währenddessen
agiert noch eine der leistungsstärksten
wasserpumpen die je in ein fahrzeug
verbaut wurde mit einem druck von 10 bar
reicht der wasserstrahl über 100 meter
und trifft mit einer enormen wucht auf
das muss auch so sein denkt man an die
verheerenden waldbrände nicht nur in den
[Musik]
durch die speziell konstruierte
fahrerkabine haben die feuerwehrmänner
stets das szenario im blick und können
blitzschnell bei gefahr reagieren
damit sich die einsatzkräfte zu 100
prozent auf die brandbekämpfung
konzentrieren können muss das handling
von fahrzeug und löschtechnik im
gegenzug so einfach wie möglich sein
auch für den waldbrand einsatz geeignet
der großen wasservorrat des fahrzeugs
viele gerade bei anwendungen die
möglichkeit das fahrzeug auf den bald
einsetzen zu können und
dies entsprechend so getestet und wird
auch hier so getestet dass man
wallfahrten problemlos darstellen
durch den allradantrieb auf allen drei
achsen klebt das fahrzeug praktisch auf
dem untergrund und bewältigt selbst
kritische situationen mühelos
die enorme ps kraft sorgt zudem für den
notwendigen schub
die bodenfreiheit unterstreicht nochmal
die geländetauglichkeit und den einsatz
auf schwierigem terrain
[Musik]
über zwei tage wird das fahrzeug geprüft
später muss es im eiskalten sibirien
ebenso einsatzbereit sein wie bei
brütender hitze in der wüste
sandiger boden darf ebenso kein
hindernis sein wie morast dabei lassen
die tester kein szenario aus auch im
wald geht es um zeit also wird das gas
bleiben möglich kräftig durchgedrückt
mit den tests sicher werk dass das
fahrzeug im normalen einsatz alltag von
den feuerwehrleuten vom einsatz konnten
gut bedient werden kann dass es den
belastungen die dort aufgewachsen ist
und
der feuerwehrmann oder das
einsatzpersonal sich auf den original
auftrag das heißt also auf die bedienung
der löschtechnik und auch die
brandbekämpfung und menschenrettung
konzentrieren können und das fahrzeug
dabei bestmöglich unterstützt und hier
war zu weil er sich seinen dienst tut
bislang wurden die giganten
hauptsächlich von männern gesteuert doch
der wdr zeigt das wird sich in zukunft
ändern denn auch frauen wie kathleen
roman finden an der feuerwehr immer mehr
gefallen
jetzt für die feuerwehr entschieden und
ich fand das immer sehr faszinierend
feuerwehr und das eigentlich so ein
kindheitstraum irgendwann war zur
berufsfeuerwehr zu gehen
so was halt genau die gleiche arbeit
machen wie die männer auch und dann ist
es schon gar nicht mehr so kämpfen
sondern man ist teil von einem team und
integriert sich halt ganz normal wieder
andere nehmen
und dann sogar bei der feuerwache des
neuen berliner flughafens
inzwischen ist sie zum zugführer
aufgestiegen und gibt bei einsätzen das
kommando
zum alltag zählt die theorie und vor
allem das riesige gelände des neuen
hauptstadtflughafens erst einmal
kennenzulernen
[Musik]
alle wichtigen schlüsselpositionen
müssen abgespeichert und beim einsatz
sofort abgerufen werden
alle szenarien wie das überziehen der
schutzkleidung werden immer und immer
wieder trainiert aber
auch der psychologische umgang wie
werden die oft auch dramatischen
rettungseinsätze verarbeitet das erstmal
nicht so sehr an sich ran lassen ist
jetzt einfach gesagt aber gerade im team
entspricht nach den einsätzen über das
geschehene um ganz einfach im team das
ganze ist auszuwerten und man geht nach
hause und hat dann dort seine familie
hat dann dort ein ganz normales
familienleben und schaltet zu hause dann
ab und versucht das alles irgendwo außen
kopf zu kriegen oder
man lenkt sich einfach mitarbeit ab denn
auf der flug wache gibt es immer etwas
zu tun so zum beispiel die wartung der
geräte
frage unser gerätetraining vor
ganz einfach uns noch mal kurz die
funktionsweise von schere spreizer zu
erklären keiner erklärt den anderen
kollegen noch mal kurz wie es
funktioniert damit einfach die
handhabung
über
die anforderungen und herausforderungen
sind bei einer flughafenfeuerwehr
weitaus höher als bei einer freiwilligen
feuerwehr auf dem land daher ist die
ausrüstung spezifischer komplexer und am
ende umfassender
die mannschaften setzten sich täglich
damit auseinander und geben ihre
erfahrungen auch an die hersteller der
fahrzeuge weiter um am ende selbst bei
der nächsten generation von einer
optimierung profitieren zu können
entsprechend ist die feuerwache auch am
ber aufgestellt
flughafen
flugzeuge ist technik die man ja immer
mein feuerwehr nicht
wir haben große flugfeld löschfahrzeuge
ist natürlich etwas besonderes als
feuerwehrauto
wir haben offen wie er einen
eisenbahntunnel unten drunter und ein
bahnhof wo natürlich das ganze spektrum
tunnel brandbekämpfung und eisenbahnen
brandbekämpfung noch dazu kommen
und an sich ist ja der bär eine eigene
kleine stadt
von der notlandung eines flugzeuges bis
hin zu einem eingeklemmten fluggast in
einem aufzug in jedem szenario muss
binnen sekunden die richtige
entscheidung getroffen werden
die handhabung der technik
logischerweise dass das alles sitzt das
man vorher nicht mehr überlegen muss die
flugzeug brandbekämpfung wird trainiert
dass man wirklich ohne fehler und
schnellstmöglich für jegliche einsätze
gerüstet ist
allerdings geht es im einundzwanzigsten
jahrhundert nicht nur um technik und
leistung sondern auch um das design ja
ein feuerwehrfahrzeug soll nicht nur
funktionell und effektiv sondern
heutzutage auch ein hingucker sein und
dafür zeichnet max ruhdorfer mit seinen
studien und visionen verantwortlich
beim design von bei dieser auslegung der
strategie ist die innovation
wir wollen in zukunft innovative
attraktive produkte leisten dazu gehört
die technologie aber das ganze handling
und das ganze aussehen ist entsprechend
wichtig etwas was gut aussieht wird
wahrgenommen auch als was modernes was
die neue technologie hat und was in der
regel auch gut funktioniert design ist
ein optisches versprechen oder die
qualität die technologie was ein produkt
in zukunft hat und das muss man
verkörpern weil im endeffekt das
fahrzeug wenn es um flughafen ist immer
ein repräsentant der sicherheit und
jeder fahrgast oder jeder reisende fühlt
sich eben wohl wenn er so ein
hochtechnologie
fahrzeug auch sieht und erlebt und das
sollte man dann auch als firma
verkörpern
der look der fahrzeuge gewinnt immer
mehr an bedeutung
ohne ihren eigentlichen zweck zu verein
trächtigen
bei uns geht es nicht um schönheit es
geht auch nicht um gefallen sondern es
geht um attraktivität und ehrlichkeit
robustheit
dynamisch kräftig das auszudrücken in
unserer kantigkeit polygon heftigkeit
das ist eine wiedererkennung die wir uns
auf die fahne geschrieben haben
max ruhdorfer lässt sich bei seiner
arbeit von unterschiedlichen motiven und
visuellen begebenheiten inspirieren
so kann die frontansicht auch schon mal
in einem raubtier geboren sein
der hai in der feuerwehr
etwas sehr dynamisches wieder
erkennbares aus der tierwelt zum
beispiel einen hai der ja sehr gut die
kantigkeit aber auch fließende formen
miteinander verbindet
der konstruktivistische formen uns
angeschaut und sind dann zu einer
formensprache gekommen über den diamant
über so eine kantigkeit und haben das in
verschiedenen stufen
konzipiert und umgelegt immer mit der
prämisse dass die kantigkeit die
flächigkeit umgesetzt wird in
sichtbarkeit und durchsicht flächen für
die windschutzscheibe
wichtig ist dass im prinzip jetzt
der schritt erfolgt die konzeption von
so einer kanzel von innen nach außen zu
bringen also auch den fahrerarbeitsplatz
entsprechend so zu gestalten wie zum
beispiel die freiräume zu schaffen damit
dann auch hier die freiräume tatsächlich
auch durchsichtig und buch blickt ba
sind
damit man in division fantasie und
enorme kreativität von max ruhdorfer
eintauchen kann sie erleben kann setzt
man am besten eine 3d brille auf
mit dem lenkrad den bedienelementen
joystick und mittelkonsole
kannst du mal beschreiben wie so ein
raumeindruck ist von der kabine
insgesamt ist erscheint auf jeden fall
wahnsinnig groß die chance noch deutlich
von mir weg und ich sehe einfach wie
enorm und platz ich da haben wie das
einige leute platz haben müssen und nur
nach zum biker selbst nicht wie man es
aus dem pkw kennt sondern gefühlt
doch nicht nur die gestaltung des
innenraumes kann in 3d dargestellt auch
bestimmte szenarien wie eine
brandbekämpfung können mit der software
im wahrsten sinne hautnah nachgestellt
werden
da kannst du erkennen und ich glaube du
kannst jetzt auch beginnen das wasser
wirft
da kommt auch schon her gefahren
dann kann man glaube ich den
wasserstrahl auf erfolgen
und kann das dann so mitverfolgen wie
sich der wasserstrahl bewegt
noch bevor der erste reifen montiert die
pumpe angeschraubt oder der werfer am
fahrzeug aufgesetzt wird sehen die
techniker zumindest durch die brille die
zukunft der brandbekämpfung
mit diesem fahrzeug werden die flughäfen
rund um den globus noch sicher war und
die chance ein brennendes wrack leben zu
verlassen steigt
wer sicherheit nach außen vermittelt
muss auch selbstsicher sein daher wird
die fahrerkabine unterschiedlichen und
genormten crashtests unterzogen
im falle von frontalaufprall
und durch die anderen szenarien werden
weiterhin abgesichert ein umkippen des
fahrzeugs auf die seite und das rutschen
gegen eines brückenpfeilers immerhin
wird hier eine der weltweit größten
fahrerkabinen auf der test an richtung
fixiert auch das ist neuland für prüfer
und ingenieure die kabine wird
bestimmten kräften ausgesetzt und muss
bei einem aufprall die sicherheit der
insassen garantieren alle sind gespannt
auf das ergebnis nach dem großen knall
nach dem crash folgt sofort die analyse
zwar sind die dummies mit sensoren
verbunden eine direkte begutachtung
lässt allerdings schon einige schlüsse
ziehen wurden die personen leicht oder
schwer verletzt oder blieben sie
unversehrt
geschlossen
überall sowie einen kleinen leuten sind
wir eingegangen wir haben hier auch eine
schöne verformung
beim crashtest versucht man so
authentisch wie möglich ein echtes
unfallszenario zu simulieren so werden
gewichte winkel und geschwindigkeit
entsprechend eingestellt
es war sehr positiv
wir haben
und die kabine ist weiterhin auf ihren
platz ist also nicht vom chassis
abgerissen
jetzt folgt das zweite test szenario in
dem der direkte aufprall zum beispiel an
einen brückenpfeiler nachgestellt wird
[Musik]
stundenlange vorbereitung für wenige
sekunden crash
[Musik]
vom nichts dem zufall zu überlassen wird
die abfolge mehrfach wiederholt es wäre
schlichtweg fahrlässig wenn hier eine
verformung oder ein sprung übersehen
wird die kräfte müssen richtig
absorbiert und abgeleitet werden
natürlich darf da der freie raum also
der sitzplatz an sich und der darauf
sitzen damit nicht verletzt werden die
kabine muss auf dem prüfstein bleiben
und die türen sollten geschlossen
bleiben
dadurch habe ich mir natürlich die
sicherheit dass den feuerwehrleuten dort
nichts dramatisches passieren kann
natürlich hinterlässt der aufprall seine
spuren das soll er auch
aber eine erkenntnis ist am ende des
tages wichtig der crafter ich bin dazu
diese sicherheit nachzuweisen und
feuerwehrleute das sicherheit zu geben
dass wenn ein unfall passiert was
hoffentlich nie passiert
ihr überleben gesichert ist darauf kann
sich das team in berlin verlassen und
sich voll auf seine übungen und einsätze
konzentrieren
wie bei diesem speziellen stachel dass
wir neben dem front monitoren dem dach
monitor hat noch die möglichkeit haben
zusätzlich ein piercing tun zu haben
womit wir halt eine flugzeug in
brandbekämpfung bei frachtmaschinen
durchführen können ohne dass wir selber
direkt als druck vorgehen müssen sondern
wir können mit einer lanze die
flugzeughaut durchstechen und können
beginnen dann im wasser nebel erzeugen
wie beim piercing wird die nadel durch
die flugzeughaut betrieben was dann
folgt ist kein lifestyle sondern
schlicht rettung von menschenleben in
der kabine
jetzt im hintergrund kann man sehr schön
sehen das fahrzeug ist neben dem front
und dem dach werfer und dem löschen
vorne noch mit einem sogenannten
castingtour ausgestattet was uns
ermöglicht eine flugzeug brandbekämpfung
durchzuführen was muss man sich
vorstellen wie löscher wird auf dem
rumpf aufgedrückt und anschließend wird
eine lanze durch das durch die
flugzeughaut durchgesprochen und innen
drinnen kann man dann einen wassernebel
erzeugen der einem möglichen brand innen
drin bekämpfen könnte
ein vordringen der mannschaft ist oft
nicht möglich daher ist der staffel die
ideale lösung von außen die flammen zu
löschen und die enormen temperaturen
abzukühlen
natürlich die luftfahrtindustrie steht
auch nicht da wären die flugzeuge wärme
moderner entwickeln sich weiter und
dementsprechend müssen wir als flughafen
feuerwehr natürlich dieser entwicklung
ebenfalls gerecht werden und unseren
fuhrpark erneuern und moderne halten
und hier können sich die flughafen
wachen weltweit auf die ingenieure in
giengen verlassen man ist am puls der
zeit und öffnet für den neuen z6 die
tore
dieses spezielle löschfahrzeug ist heute
das maß aller dinge doch die visionen
kennen kein ende schon jetzt tüfteln die
ingenieure an der nächsten generation
noch schön noch schneller und noch
effizienter soll sie sein
so imposant bewegend und emotional diese
fahrzeuge sind hoffen wir dass sie nie
im ernstfall zum einsatz kommen müssen
[Musik]
[Applaus]